>> Chris: IT'S TIME FOR
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG WARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A HASHTAG
AND PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK
AND FOR EACH CORRECT EXAMPLE YOU
WILL GET A HUNDRED POINTS.
IN HONOR OF EMINEM'S NEW ALBUM
DROPPING TODAY WE DECIDED TO DO
A FUN RAPPING HASHTAG SO
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS CRAPPY
RAPPERS.
NOW, I LOVE EMINEM, WE'RE NOT
SAYING EMINEM IS CRAPPY.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR POOP-THEMED
RAPPER NAMES BECAUSE I AM 14 AND
A HALF YEARS OLD.
(LAUGHTER)
SO EXAMPLES OF THESE WOULD BE
NUMBER 2 CHAINZ OR STOOLIO OR
DROP THE KIDS OFF AT THE POOL MO
D.
OUR CAMERA MAN SAID RUNS D.M.C.
START NOW.
ILIZA?
>> RICK ROSS DRESSED FOR LESS.
>> Chris:LY TAKE IT.
YES.
POINTS.
YES, SFROOES
>> STOOLIO?
>> Chris: WELL, I UNDERSTAND
THAT, I ALREADY SAID STUL OWE.
>> I HEARD YOU SAY THAT ONE.
>> Chris: I SAID IT AGAIN JUST
NOW BUT YOU ARE FOREIGN TO OUR
LAND SO I WILL GIVE YOU POINTS.
ILIZA?
>> 50 CENTED CANDLES.
>> Chris: YES!
THESE AREN'T POOP BUT THEY'RE
ADORABLE.
YES?
>> A.S.A.P. KHAKI.
THAT MEANS DO DO.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RHYS.
>> M.C.W.C..
>> Chris: WATER CLOSET!
I GET REFERENCE!
YES, I'LL GIVE YOU A HUNDRED
POINTS.
ILIZA?
>> JAY COLONOSCOPY.
>> Chris: WELL PLAYED.
MOVING OFF THE CANDLES.